sorry you've been very crazy with how
you kind of made your phones recently in
particular with your short film the Holy
Family haven't you and also tell me a
little bit about your latest film that
you've been working on to serum which we
just finished as those budgets I've
worked with since before Life of Brian
yeah so it's like if I'm the first time
film director of the independent
director and uh and what we have is a
pretty extraordinary cast with Christoph
Waltz playing the lead and then and
David Thewlis bro Matt Damon Ben Whishaw
Sanjeev Bhaskar um Peter star ma who
probably forgot some of the others who
basically came in and worked for Brazil
for nothing
Tilda Swinton's in there as well and
everybody just participating in this
thing and it was made and we were able
to make it because of that that kind of
willingness to join the circus for a bit
and see what happens have you seen the
movie industry change over the years cuz
here for the 15th year the British
Independent Film Awards you've been in
the film industry longer than that
Avenue have you seen it change it's
become boring frankly the studio's just
churn out is these big blockbusters they
only see the good thing about them is
that you know people who huge number of
British actors get to go and work with
them and get paid a lot of money I hope
so that then they could work on smaller
independent films that's a good thing
but other man I find it tedious now in
the kind of films that are being made I
mean I just I can tell you what's gonna
happen almost all the time the whole
point of cinema is to be surprised all
the time but not to be in a story they
don't know where it's gonna go the big
ones seem to just have to reassure the
audience by giving the same baby food
time and time again it's just dressed up
in more elaborate costumes that's all
it's a chance for people to actually
have you know unique visions unique
ideas what it really means about
independent filmmaking is that you don't
have any money to do big blockbusters
but independent filmmaking really means
but at least hopefully they're you know
fresh ideas the studios and the big
films it becomes so Factory like you
know you know I just was in I was
watching Seven Psychopaths last night
and the trailers up to that I thought
I've seen all those films a billion
times already for the last 30 years I've
seen the same stuff that's what it feels
like and I think it's it's a really sad
time and that's why it's something like
Seven Psychopaths is great I mean is a
completely fresh voice in Martin
Martin's writing is brilliant as
directing is that so that's what it's
about I mean it's it's listen
everybody's dependent on something about
how small your film is whether you're
it's your grandmother giving you the
money or a French own distributor giving
you money it's all the same you have to
beg and borrow and hopefully you end up
making something that you are proud of
and you can take the blame for what it
doesn't work because that's part of the
thing it's not it's not just having a
good idea it's carrying it through and
if it works
hey if not get another job how about
Johnny Depp getting back on that horse
for Don Quixote
it's his horse he's not on my horse we
shall see where this goes
you